he uh goes holy [ __ ] juicy will smith
smacked chris rock
and when i first saw it i'm like oh
that's it was this fake but then when
will sits down
and he's like keep your my wife's name
out your f in mouth i'm like oh well
they're not going to script cuss words
because they can't play it no matter
what this is real oh damn this is real
and then you watch it and you're going
to play it here chin yeah 47 million
views
it's probably more now i've got if i
refresh it so before you go to this so
this is will walking up and slapping
chris rock right
so
before you play it
previous to this
there's a lot to go into here so
previous before this chris rock uh who's
a one of the greatest comedians ever do
it he uh made a reference that about
jada pinkett smith that she uh he can't
wait to see gi jane tube because she has
a bald head right so gi jane shaves her
head
jada peeking smith has a condition of on
her scalp this condition i forget what's
called
alopecia
where uh it like grows in patches and
you know it's not good so
he makes a joke about that um
and will when you watch it on the replay
is laughing he laughs at the joke but
jada piggy and smith is not laughing so
i think that's where uh will's like oh i
better do something or otherwise she's
gonna hook up with lil wayne or some
[ __ ] so he goes up there we'll get to
that there's a reason why he did this
so he walks up there live during the
oscars
and slaps the [ __ ] out of chris rock
good technique too left hand is high for
the counter slap you know i think his
training from ali paid off a little bit
there but you see this play it chin
i hope we can play this in the actual
video
because twitter
wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my wife
and then he has to do like the oscars
for the best documentary history
television
he kind of stumbles through it he does
yeah uh which rightfully so you know um
you i i
you can't either either whatever your
perspective is on this entire situation
you can't have
people slapping other people on stage
you can't have comics getting assaulted
on stage with no repercussions
um when it comes to this why because
when i watch the joke right i'm like a
gi jane joke that's not bad and then my
friends would defend and go well no she
has a condition like oh [ __ ] where's she
have cancer
man what are we talking about like no
she has alopecia and you look like
okay you can't grow hair it's not like
she has freaking you know
aids or something like some real
condition or disease or cancer where it
would trigger will smith
and then the more you look into it you
go back 2016 when chris rock was the
host of the oscars
jada pekin smith
boycotted the oscars because there
wasn't enough african-american
representatives and i think there's none
it's like all white people so she
boycotted it so chris rock's whole
bid on it which was hilarious he goes uh
and jdp smith isn't here tonight she's
boycotting the uh
the uh the uh the oscars for not enough
black representation and he goes but
she's on a tv show
he said that'd be like me boycotting
rihanna's panties because you you were
never invited
so he made those jokes about her
which again not too bad yeah a horror
i've definitely heard worse
but i think this is an accumulation of
since jada pika smith started red table
talk
the personal stories that she shares
about will and hers relationship and
this open relationship and she's had you
know she had that side piece augustus
whatever his name was and he's going on
family trip stuff like that
i think if you can be an open
relationship all good but especially
will smith who is so beloved people love
will smith we don't need to hear all
that [ __ ]
so by her starting now i'm glad she has
her own thing that's great and it's a
big show and i think they're exclusively
on facebook
but it's a big show and they have big
stars on there but by her being so open
and honest like some stuff we don't need
some some [ __ ] is private men but it's
completely changed our perspective on
will smith and he's crying on there all
the time and you just see a different
side of will smith that we don't need to
see man so
it's kind of put a black eye no pun
intended but it's put a black guy in
will smith's kind of perception when it
comes to
you know the public because it's just
crazy [ __ ] man it's like dude stand up
for yourself so i think he's being
become this butt of the joke and he's
just taken all this abuse all this abuse
and chris rock in 2016 made those jokes
about his wife and there's all this
abuse
i'm looking for the way it's it's like
he embodied the venus and serena
williams
father's
[ __ ]
persona there you know because he's a
tough dude and he defends his family at
all costs you know that guy has his
faults that's for sure that the movie
definitely leaves some stuff out
um so i think you know maybe got too
into character and started to defend his
family but i think this goes back
even way before this and i think chris
rock was just kind of the escape goat
from all the years and all the [ __ ]
and all the
the you know making fun of will and the
memes and her coming out being open
relationship and all this stuff and the
kids and i think it was just
accumulation of all that stuff led to
this because it's not in will's
character
a part of me goes
and i truly believe this like we're in a
day and age now where with the internet
and you know people remain you know
unanimous and talk all this [ __ ] and all
that stuff and there's no repercussions
so part of me goes
play stupid games win stupid prizes like
i always say and chris rock played a
stupid game talk [ __ ] about will smith's
family and
won a stupid prize and got slapped and
it's the narrative now of the oscars
but as a comic like you can't have that
we can't have
people no matter if you're will smith
one of the most famous movie stars in
the world or some random joe shmoe at a
improv walking up on stage assaulting
the comics we just can't have that in
any facet
also i'd be curious
you know a part of me feels like
obviously will's bigger than chris rock
i think chris rock is like
5
seventy pounds five eight five nine
hundred seventy pounds will smith is
maybe six two hundred ninety two hundred
pounds so he's he's bigger not like you
know way bigger but he's definitely a
bigger man
and chris rock is obviously a an artist
and talented comic and smaller guy he's
fragile
so it there's a little bit of bullying
going on here because if jason mamoa did
the same thing
would you have that same energy if jason
momoa came out there and tore into jay
to peek at smith you're gonna walk up
there and hit jason momoa i don't think
so my man i bet you're gonna have that
same energy so
it's to me it's like you know a kid in
in elementary school who's getting
bullied by the bigger kid all the time
bullied all the time he's just taken in
months goodbye he's taking a ticket and
then the skinny little twerp goes ass
kid takes all this i'm gonna jump in
here and he goes yeah man you look like
crap and then finally that kid's getting
bullied on goes oh [ __ ] this dude and
takes that on him and he's been getting
months and months of abuse
to me this is will smith taking months
and months of abuse and finally sticking
up for himself
i it's just not the right way to go
about it i i think you know hollywood
has failed with [ __ ] failed with a
man none of these guys are tough they're
just not none of them are anybody you
see on a movie they're not a tough guy
they're just not they play tough guys we
think they're tough guys but there's
also a reason why we don't know [ __ ]
about them
that there's a reason for that because
they gotta sell tickets they're not
podcasters or stand-up comics where i'll
draw a line in the santa i don't give a
[ __ ] if you don't like it a lot of
people [ __ ] with it a lot of people
won't that's the world i live in i love
that world i'll get i have a lot of
haters i have more people that love me
that's the way this works i'm gonna take
a hard stance but you're gonna know
exactly where i stand will smith can't
john cena can't the rock can't these
guys in hollywood they can't do that
because they have to appeal to the
masses you have no you have no clue
about their political beliefs you have
no clue about their personal lives you
like i saw
years ago if you remember remember when
they're like tom hanks could win the
president uh of the white house right
now he could be president of america so
many people think he's trustworthy
why because he's forrest gump are you
your [ __ ] mind we don't know that
dude he's not getting on podcasts
ripping off you know ideas or opinions
he can't he has to sell tickets he has
to sell [ __ ] save it private ryan or
some [ __ ] if he gives you a hard stance
and doubles down on you know funding the
police or whatever it is or trump or
biden or kamala harris he loses half his
fan base that's why a lot of comics
don't get political did you separate the
room right right off the bat in half no
matter what the joke is
there's some guys who do it very well
and they do do that but then some
political comics like bill maher or
something like that they take a hard
stance and that's their crowd man and
they have a huge fan base but that's it
man they're gonna ride with their home
team
actors can't do that man
they're not to me i mean obviously
they're
they inspire based off the movies the
roles that they play and the discipline
it takes to to act like that and i have
all the respect in the world for it's a
they're super talented and that's great
but as far as like real inspirational
motivational [ __ ] if you're looking
towards an actor to motivate you dude
you're barking up the wrong tree we
don't know these people that you can't
you just can't and that's part of the
reason you know i think you know a lot
of these actors don't come out and you
we have no idea about what they
personally believe in because they don't
cut their ticket sales in half whether
it's in china like john cena remember
when he messed up and started speaking
mandarin and [ __ ]
for the rock with with rogan man how
fast he backtracked and was like no [ __ ]
he has tickets to sell dude that's
that's the name of their game we have no
idea
they're the softest people in the world
man [ __ ] hits the fan they will do
whatever it takes
to make sure that their credibility and
their likeness stays in good standing no
matter what it is they always walk the
middle there's never a real opinion out
of them they're the fakest people in the
world we have no idea about them so for
will smith back to will smith
i think you know jadis pinkett smith
doing this red table talk
they give you a look inside will smith's
world which is
kind of weird to be honest i don't want
to know
will smith is a cuck i don't want to
know that stuff i don't need that uh
that's my you know mike lowry or
whatever you know i don't need that in
my life i don't i don't need to know i
don't want to see him crying because
girl was flying a dude out on their
family vacation getting dick on the side
while the kids were at the pool
what
fresh prince of bel-air it's all good
baby get jiggy with it i don't need to
know all this stuff
but he became the butt of the joke
took it for years years years then
finally the smaller guy the innocent
comic not even a good i mean is whatever
joke it's not like you roasted the [ __ ]
out of her tell you what chris rock has
a chin though
chris rock has a chin on him
i can't imagine being slapped like that
in poor chris rock i mean this can be
talked about for how long
i was texting the group about it
i said
no in hollywood i've been my fair share
of hollywood parties man no in hollywood
i will guarantee you at an after party
those two get together
and they're friends now i said i
wouldn't be surprised if we get a
picture of them together you know will
apologizing or something like that
and sure enough p diddy said that you
know p diddy combs or whatever was like
yeah they're all good they're the after
party together they're all good
okay you know i just think this was uh
just the final straw on the camel's back
that broke will smith because he's been
getting so much [ __ ] being a [ __ ] and
doing all this stuff and let his girl
get all wild and was like god damn will
you know
so i think finally stood up for himself
against the smaller guy
my question is would you have kept the
same energy with jason mamoa or the rock
i bet you won't do [ __ ] if he's one of
them you know so
um
we're talking about it so most oscars
have been talked about people like you
know this this takes away from all the
hard work of the workers and [ __ ] hey
hate to tell you i watched the oscars it
was awful if this didn't happen we're
not talking about it at all this is the
best thing happened to oscars and i
don't know how long dude i don't know
how long in a long ass time because
we're all talking about it
um you know i also think just from comic
to comic i think too you know amy
schumer knows chris rock really well
really really well he's a mentor of hers
if let's say
theo vaughn was hosting the oscars could
happen
could happen he was blowing up dude
let's say theo's hosting the oscars or
any award show didn't have to be the
oscars
and some dude slapped theo
and i was
like hosting it you know what i'm saying
like i was one of the
correspondents
i'm not just gonna be like oh man like
she came out like man i heard something
happen what happened everyone's laughing
you know what
your boy just got slapped dude defend
him
then you you use your skill set that
you've developed over the years and she
used to be an amazing roaster
tear into a man defend your friend
that's hollywood in a nutshell people
it's like you turn a light on
cockroaches they [ __ ] sprint all the
ways there's no they're not they don't
have each other's back because they they
can't they would they would they they
have pr people in there going be careful
this will stuff man you say the wrong
thing you know your movie comes out next
summer it could be a bad look you know
they can't they can't they can't stick
up for each other
end of the day bunch of [ __ ] yeah we
all look up to them like they're heroes
they're not heroes man they're fake
people
that's why that happened it was just
years and years of abuse and will being
the the
brunt of jokes left and right and
finally he's had enough and it was a
smaller guy and he could take advantage
of it
we're talking about it
it was so awkward yeah it was hilarious
my favorite is the woman who's from uh
black panther sent behind will smith
she's just like this the whole time just
like what and the [ __ ] is happening yeah
it's hilarious
it's all like again it's just such a
petty thing to do again part of me is
like oh you stuck up for your family
good for you man there's
way better ways to the other thing is
like you'd have to embarrass him do it
on national tv you could have went in
the back you know and had an altercation
talk to a man-to-man that'd been cool
you know there's different ways to
handle it but just as a comic myself
we can't have people going on stage
assaulting comics over jokes we can't
have it man
you know i'm glad chris rock isn't
pressing charges you know i wouldn't
either i just like what are you doing
dude it's just it's tough for chris
right for chris rocky in a weird
position i really really wish he went
back to his old new york coming up at
the stand and all that old chops and
really lit leaned into it lit him up
he would have said i mean not that he
needs any more help with his career but
if you would have torn them use that as
you know material and really
tore into the smith family and there's
so much content there that had been the
move that would have went so viral for
chris rock we wouldn't be talking about
the slap we were talking about him
lighting will smith up that'd been the
move
or amy schumer could have done that
that's not hollywood man she's hollywood
now you know so there you go
what else you got jim i have a feeling
he's gonna do something chris yeah like
something i don't think so really
it's not in their nature it's not
hollywood
i don't need to do anything i bet you
they come out together make a joke out
of it i bet you we get a video in the
next month
guarantee it
all right well and something was going
on because even before the award show
will smith took a picture with j p g
smith and was like we got all dressed up
for chaos tonight like he knew something
was going down you know like he knew
chris maybe from 2016 comments like he
he had that you know weird energy about
him
and then he won an oscar and all of
hollywood's clapping for him for five
minutes let him talk it's like he just
assaulted a guy on stage
weird that's hollywood nutshell man